2007's coming-of-age comedy Superbad provided
a treasure trove of one-liners, hilarious
moments, and unforgettable characters.
But it's hard to argue that there's anyone
more iconic than the fake-ID-sporting uber-geek,
McLovin.
The role even earned then 17-year-old actor
Christopher Mintz-Plasse an MTV Movie Award
nom for Best Breakthrough Performance.
While Superbad certainly helped springboard
some of its actors onto bigger and better
things, we haven't seen too much of Mintz-Plasse
lately.
Let's find out what adult McLovin looks like
today.
"I am McLovin."
Becoming Fishlegs
Not many people realize that Mintz-Plasse
is a prominent voice in the How to Train Your
Dragon franchise.
In 2010's action-fantasy, Mintz-Plasse voiced
the enthusiastic Fishlegs, a young viking
whose bulky body appears in sharp contrast
to the actor's skinny McLovin voice.
"Hi, I'm Fishlegs. I've heard a lot about you. Clearly not enough."
Mintz-Plasse digs doing voice work for family-friendly
fare, telling Hypable,
"I love it, man.
It's exciting because most of my movies are
rated R, and I go in there and I'm trying
to make kids laugh, so it's cool to do a PG
movie.
And you can go in wearing sweatpants and do
it."
Kick-ass moves
Mintz-Plasse's second most famous role is
that of superhero-turned-supervillain, Chris
"Red Mist" D'Amico, in Kick-Ass and Kick-Ass
2.
That is, until his character changed his name.
"Henceforth, I'll be known as The Motherf---er."
The big-screen role was actually written with
Mintz-Plasse in mind, but the actor thinks
the original character from the Marvel comic
is cooler.
He told CinemaBlend,
"[He's] much cooler than I am.
They wanted my father to be a badass, and
I've never been accepted by him.
They wanted that instead of the cool guy who's
always smoking and getting the girls."
Nevertheless, the role landed Mintz-Plasse
a nomination at the 2010 Teen Choice Awards.
Hollywood remake
In 2011, Mintz-Plasse landed the role of "Evil
Ed" Lee in the comedic remake of 1985's horror
flick, Fright Night.
"I really hate to be the one to tell you this,
but that guy your neighbor, yeah, he's a vampire."
Originally, Mintz-Plasse wasn't feeling a
reboot, but he couldn't pass up the chance
to work with Colin Farrell.
Mintz-Plasse told HitFix,
"I'm not the biggest fan of remakes, cuz I
sit and watch the trailers and I'm like, 'God,
just think of a new freakin idea,' y'know?"
But, he was on board once he saw the cast
list.
"I saw that Anton and Colin and Greg and Craig
were all attached."
"If done right it could be this really memorable
role for the movie."
Almost a sitcom star
In 2012, Mintz-Plasse was on track to have
his own TV series, Friend Me, by writer Alan
Kirschenbaum.
Unfortunately, Friend Me was canceled after
Kirschenbaum passed away.
Mintz-Plasse tweeted,
"RIP Alan.
Only [worked] with you for 10 days, but thanks
so much for this wonderful job.
You were a funny, great guy."
But Mintz-Plasse landed on TV for real, when
he booked 2016's The Great Indoors.
"Jack Gordon?
It is so incredible to meet you, I'm Clark,
online content curator."
"Hi, Clark, obviously made up job title!"
While the show was cancelled after just one
season, Mintz-Plasse's performance proved
he could be sitcom gold in the right part.
Musically inclined
Mintz-Plasse has appeared in a slew of music
videos.
Perhaps most notably, he played drums in Kid
Cudi's late-'60s-inspired "Erase Me."
Mintz-Plasse also appeared alongside Kick-Ass
costar Chloë Grace Moretz for The Soft Pack's
"Answer to Yourself," as well as Unknown Mortal
Orchestra's "So Good At Being in Trouble."
Most recently, he starred as a kidnapper in
Alison Wonderland's "U Don't Know," and as
a man who overcomes life in a wheelchair,
in Kodaline's "Ready."
Rocking out
Mintz-Plasse isn't just music video eye-candy.
He's also in a band.
After playing drums for Young Rapscallions
for eight years before they broke up, Mintz-Plasse
and his friend Adam Aseraf say they started
getting high, jamming out in the backyard,
and calling themselves Bear on Fire.
When they realized that things were getting
groovy, the duo recruited some friends and
released their first studio album in 2015.
Though shouts for "McLovin" inevitably follow
the actor wherever he plays, Mintz-Plasse
doesn't mind.
He told Stereogum,
"I just want as many people to come to the
show and as many people to hear my music as
possible."
Going dark
When it comes to future work, Mintz-Plasse
is most interested in darker, more dramatic
roles.
However, going dark in the Kick-Ass series
wasn't the easiest thing for the actor.
He told The Belfast Telegraph,
"I read the script, and I was nervous because
it's unlike anything I've ever done before,
so I got an acting coach.
A month before filming, we would go through
every scene and every line and figure out
where the character needed to go emotionally."
Mintz-Plasse also studied some other villainous
characters from the big-screen to help him
get it right.
And some from real life, too.
He said,
"I watched Heath Ledger's Joker quite a bit,
and I researched [Marvel's] The Punisher.
I [also] watched this really dark serial killer
on trial—I studied his eyes and how lifeless
they were and tried to use that too."
A far cry from McLovin's innocent baby face,
but these days, he truly wants to kick some
ass.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!